nos piden resolver para ayer y nos dan
menos la raíz cúbica de i es igual a 4
la raíz cúbica de 5 en este tipo de
ecuaciones lo primero que hacemos es
dejar de un lado solo los radicales y a
partir de ahí eliminar dichos radicales
para esta ecuación lo más fácil es que
pasemos los radicales del lado izquierdo
para esto vamos a restar 4 raíz cúbica
de y a ambos lados restamos raíz cúbica
no no necesitamos restar menos 4 raíz
cúbica de y ya está del lado izquierdo y
también lo hacemos del lado derecho
menos 4 raíz cúbica de g así que del
lado izquierdo nos queda tenemos menos
la raíz cúbica de y menos 4 la raíz
cúbica de y si tenemos menos una raíz
cúbica de y le agregamos menos 4 raíz
cúbica de que nos queda menos 5 raíz
cúbica de iu y del lado derecho estos
dos términos se cancelan eso era lo que
queríamos originalmente dejar la raíz
cúbica de y tan solo
del lado izquierdo así es que esto nos
queda únicamente igual a 5 este 5 que
tenemos acá y ya casi dejamos sola la
raíz cúbica de y tan sólo nos falta
dividir ambos lados
entre menos 5 hagamos eso dividimos
entre menos 5 el lado izquierdo y
dividimos entre menos 5 el lado derecho
este menos 5 y menos 5 se cancelan y nos
queda del lado izquierdo la raíz cúbica
de iu y del lado derecho 5 entre -5 es
igual a menos 1 ahora podríamos la
manera más fácil y directa sería elevar
al cubo ambos lados para obtener
entonces la solución de esta ecuación o
también podemos considerar que esto es
equivalente esta expresión es
equivalente a que a la un tercio es
igual a menos uno son dos maneras
equivalentes de establecer lo mismo pues
ya la un tercio es lo mismo que raíz
cúbica de y así es que elevando al cubo
a ambos lados de la ecuación elevamos al
cubo ambos lados de la ecuación también
lo hace de aquí con esta ecuación
equivalente le vamos al cubo ambos lados
tenemos bueno aquí tenemos ya un tercio
elevado al cubo es lo mismo que elevar
al a un tercio por tres esto es lo mismo
que elevar a la primera potencia lo
mismo que tenemos acá si sacamos la raíz
cúbica de ella y luego elevamos al cubo
las operaciones se cancelan para obtener
finalmente que igual a menos 1 al cubo
menos un al cubo es menos 1 por menos
uno es 1 positivo por menos 1 es igual a
menos 1 que igual a menos 1 es nuestra
solución ahora verifiquemos que
efectivamente funciona regresemos a la
ecuación original en donde en vez de y
voy a poner menos 1 tenemos menos la
raíz cúbica de y que es menos 1 lo cual
tiene que ser igual a 4 por la raíz
cúbica de menos 1 más
5 veamos si esto se cumple la raíz
cúbica de menos 1 es menos 1 pues menos
1 al cubo es menos 1 así es que esto va
a ser menos -1 que tiene que ser igual a
4 x
la raíz cúbica menos uno es menos uno
más
5 - menos uno es uno positivo esto es
igual a 4 x menos 1 menos 45 menos 45 es
igual a 1 y hemos verificado
exitosamente que nuestra solución es la
correcta